me and my partner we did our best
nellie's journey on dancing with the
stars came to an
end on monday's season 29 finale
the couple in third place is
nelly and daniela the rapper and his pro
partner daniella finished in third place
and while he wanted to take home the
coveted mirror ball trophy
he's still proud how badly did you want
to win this and how do you feel that you
didn't get there to the full mirror ball
in the end
i mean of course you want to win you
know what i'm saying you've been doing
this for almost three months
um you've been putting yourself through
training that you've never had a day in
your life you're trying to
you're going against people who've
basically studied this in college
you understand like is that about me
the winner
i mean you know but i mean obviously
obviously
you know it's still a competition and
you use whatever you have to win
so it's not it's it's not a bad thing
it's just
it's just a thing you know what i mean
so you want to work that much harder
because you know
a lot of the odds are stacked up against
you yeah while nelly beat out fourth
place finalist justina machado and her
pro partner
sasha bachelorette alum caitlyn bristow
and dancing with the stars pro artem
won the whole thing and catfish star
neve shulman
and his partner jenna came in second do
you feel
frustrated that other people had all
this background in this training and you
came in without it
i would have liked to know that going
into it
if i could say that if i could say that
i just
would like to have known that coming
into it
that's all that's all you're saying you
know what i mean it's like yo you know
you don't want to get sideswiped once
you get in now
my thing is if i know that coming into
it then i can't ever say anything about
it because i knew it but you can't come
into a competition then find out what's
going on
but that being said not to sound like
that she deserves to win and she wants
she deserves to win she danced
beautifully
she again she's a sweet person she did a
thing now you're asking the competitive
side of nelly
if you're asking the competitive side of
nelly then he's going to say that if
you're asking
nelly as a you know as a person as a
star then
i mean it's all congratulations because
she deserves that she danced
beautifully every week and she did her
thing if you'd known that there were
going to be
fellow competitors who had that dance
experience would you have done the show
uh probably not because you don't you
don't stack yourself up against that
i mean it's just like yo why would i why
would i get in a boxing match with
somebody who's been boxing since they
were 12.
the 46 year old rapper really held his
own this season
and on monday nelly and daniela
performed two dances
[Music]
the pair recreated their week five samba
earning them a 27 out of 30.
but it was their freestyle routine that
really got the judges amped
this dance gives me hope because it was
like a hybrid
of hip hop and ballroom and latin two
worlds that you would not normally put
together
you guys brought them together and
created something so magical you give me
hope for the future
it's a phenomenal show and what makes it
a phenomenal show is the people
the people in front of the camera and
the people behind the camera i'ma miss
everybody from the runners to the
producers to the judges
to everybody you know what i mean like
and it's it's definitely a phenomenal
experience man and i i'm very happy i
did it